no no more stars all right then and get
the party started
this show is brought to you by datsu
Sara go to dsgear.com and use Cobra Joey
to get five percent off all their
extremely high quality functional gear
that's made with hemp textiles they have
bags Keys rash guards and more that's
datsu Sara and go to dsgear.com and use
Cobra Joey to save five percent
show is also brought to you by on it go
to audit.com and use code word church to
save 10 on all the great optimization
products like Alpha Brain new mood
shrimtek immune and shroom tech support
we're all in [__] fear
but what are you gonna do
it's Monday
June 27th
are you kidding me or what
I'm trying to tell you [__]
Monday [__]
Uncle Joe is here
we ain't [__] around fresh from
Philly
there you go
oh [__]
are you [__] kidding me or what
who opens up with sticks nobody even
remembers [__] stick
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here my main little Jew ish
brother Lee syat hello from the [__]
Israeli side of the science big envelope
it's got so much loot you don't even
know how much money he got because the
interest and then my main man
Chris taught Loa in the [__] house
he's gonna break down a couple things
for you [__] before we get this
party started how you doing today Chris
very good talking to the mic I'm doing
very good you look good thank you very
much I like the new hair color
everything's beautiful here I gotta tell
you guys I never leave a town and I got
to start doing it more often I want to
thank the people who came to the five
shows in Philly
you guys uh well some of the [__]
best crowds I run into a long goddamn
time you weren't sensitive about nothing
you took the ride nobody uh it was
tremendous I want to thank you from the
bottom of my heart for making me feel
special all right and uh
it's just a great [__] time man
sometimes you forget how good some of
these [__] American cities are
meanwhile everybody wants to go do this
and that and you just have to tap in
and you see the beauty of these [__]
cities and Phillies especially East
Coast Philly's great on every angle
because there's history [__] there's
baseball there's food I went to a
24-hour diner both of these waitresses
could never win a beauty contest
they have been smoking since the age of
eight they were in their 60s and they
worked the midnight shift listen I don't
give a [__] if you're a black belt Jiu
Jitsu you're not taking all these
[__] down they've seen it all in
Philadelphia one worked for 18 years the
other one I mean it was tremendous I
went into every day I got eggs the eggs
were [__] burnt the home fries were
horrific the bacon it was bacon but I
don't know what animal it came from
but it was delicious I just sat there
and had a great time with them
dragged my water and I gave him a
[__] final tip and I left that was
the highlight of my [__] two days
just being around normal [__] people
in a normal [__] Diner you know what
I'm saying my favorite place especially
practically something weird about
breakfast places when people go in there
every day like I usually on TV people go
to bars I never went to bars I went to
breakfast places and like they go hang
out there every day especially on the
East Coast like every McDonald's or
Dunkin Donuts you go into or 11 o'clock
yeah
oh [__]
what's up dog
nothing nice man what's going on in your
world just watching I've I've never done
anything like this so it's like oh just
checking it out yeah no no listen man ah
I met you over at Legacy Jiu Jitsu and
we had a couple discussions and uh
you know you and Leo and there's a lot
of guys over there very health conscious
it's very inspiring you know that you
see people drinking [__] water with
Chia seeds in it and people tell you
about their diets there and people bring
bananas and uh
you showed up with something a little
different you were talking to me about
CBD oils and I've been exposed to them
you know uh never taken any of them I'm
not gonna lie to you before I've never
known I was interested in the health
facets of it I had heard different
stories
I heard Pro and kind but you know what
dog I heard more [__] Pro than con
okay yeah I heard a lot more Pro than
Khan I did a benefit for a woman years
ago that had a child and she was
fighting for the kid to get it and it
was just a [__] nightmare so I have
friends in Boulder like I said that ever
since the whole uh Colorado legalization
two people on this blocks moved there
because their children had either
epileptic fits or something else was
going on and they put him on a CBD diet
and now the kids speak and they go to
school and they can play in the [__]
sun and you know so you hear all these
great effects for young people you know
I heard a car I heard that it has
effects on
dementia I read the other day that it
affects the mention that if you start as
a preventive you it fights dementia
lowers your risk of having [__]
dementia so something's got to be going
on here and somebody's lying to us do
you follow him saying to you something's
got to be going on here yeah yeah and
somebody's lying to us it I I that's a
powerful thing to say because you know
there's so much I want to say but I took
to to you know to watch ourselves in
these areas you know I I I want to just
be so open about it like like the
individuals that I have seen that have
uh that have decided to take and and uh
and and use CBD oil and properly use it
uh have uh that have had cancer that
I've known of have all done extremely
well
and the times that I've seen them doing
really well like I'm not going to say
the CBD oil is doing the work I don't
I'm not you know I'm not I'm not I just
I just know what I'm seeing and they're
doing really well and then the ones that
I have
that I that I have lost you know all my
they think people are real close to me
have uh stayed the the the use with the
the doctor's routes with the chemo and
I've watched some really good friends
pass away and and uh you know this this
last year we lost a guy named Brock
little from Hawaii he's a really uh he
was like an amazing individual he got me
into the movie industry by mistake he he
opened a lot of doors for a lot of
people's lives uh he's just the most
ballsiest yeah he was he was like one of
the most ballsiest individuals I ever
saw like in the surf world and uh we all
looked up to he's like our hero our
Superman and when we saw him get cancer
and he he wanted to hide away from it
um I didn't know how he took the CBD the
oil what type of CD oil it was or or how
the CBD oil was that was processed that
he got well you know he he kind of just
like just wanted to go already it was a
lot of pain for me passed on and had a
memorial firm this past weekend and uh
it it really put a fire under my butt to
like go looking and seeing what the
heck's going on here because that's like
the I lost a lot of good friends
recently and then though there's a lot
of kids getting this and I'm like why is
that you know and uh you know I I have a
friend of mine from Maui who was sick
for a long time he was surfing in Tahiti
when when they had that nuclear blast
out there and the wave hit him in the
face he met all these guys on this Green
Peace boat and most of the guys in the
Greenpeace boat they died except for one
guy that was down by the engine room and
bogey got hit Direct in the face with
this wave and you know he knew ready
something was wrong and and since that
time he hardly sleeps he's been going
through major surges all through his
face and everything else like that and I
and I believe that the reason why he's
still alive is because he does a
treatment called ozone and this oil this
oil is doing something that's keeping
him alive and keeping him here and you
know all the positives that he hears
that's going on with this stuff is
helping him stay strong to keep going in
this path and stay here because there's
some times where he doesn't want to be
here because the Pain's so outrageous
that he's going through but he's here
and he's here for the reasons you know
what's ozone treatment he he goes and he
goes to this machine and they take the
blood out of his body and it goes to the
machine and then when they put it back
into his body it's blue it's like a blue
color it takes all the the toxins out of
it everything I think this is what the
who's that that uh guitarist from Keith
Richards yeah I think he does this stuff
like that animal
you have a question Lee well it was I
wanted to expand on what you said the
the [__] up part is yeah I mean
medical marijuana gets a bad rap no you
can just go and say anything but if
if people are lying to us about curing
cancer that are like destroying families
it's not like oh we can cure the cold
with marijuana it's like oh we can cure
cancer
if that if like if that's what's being
lied about that's it's crazy that's what
scares me because that's the point that
I don't think you're saying is that this
cures cancer I don't want to say that
okay right let me just say this right
let me oh well I misspoke I'm sorry so
I'm not curious but it can and it can
assist in some of the negative aspects
of it all right increase uh or help with
uh your healing power whatever it does
if it does if anything helps if if doing
backflips helped and you weren't allowed
to do backflips then why like it's just
it's ridiculous yeah so um you know like
uh
there's a lot of cbd's oils out there
all these guys are making these
different different forms really doing
their best to make what they're making
I'm not going to knock any of it because
I know that this stuff works uh to a
degree I don't know what theirs is
working at how it works I just know that
ours is a step above everybody else in a
lot of ways because we have two
different type of chemical compounds in
our oil that just rock people I mean
we had a girl that was on the in the ICU
she was like a week and a half left and
she was gonna go and she had like these
Coral forming tumors sticking out of her
gut and it was bad and they wouldn't let
her put the stuff in her mouth
uh the doctors wouldn't let her put in
her mouth because they didn't know what
was in it so I started putting it on
topically and it started to dissolve and
she finally had a chance to go to sleep
and she actually slept it was the first
time she slept forever she had catheters
in there for you know to get her to do
to like dump all her toxins out of her
body and stuff and then finally the
doctors no they tested it said all this
nothing it's just glycerin ain't nothing
go ahead give it to her so they gave it
to her and she took it into her body and
all of a sudden uh within six hours or I
think six hours her she had chemo now
she got knocked with the chemo like two
days prior to this or two two or three
days prior to this
her white blood cell count went from
like zilch to 600 in six hours and then
uh within 24 hours she was going home
and she went home and then uh within two
to three weeks her tumor is reduced to
50 percent then after that they don't
know what the [__] the tumors are and
she's running around jumping around
screaming or where's my magic drops ah
she's a little girl for having a good
time and she's with her family and uh to
me that's an amazing beautiful to me
that me and my wife it was emotional for
us we cried for a while I called a I
called up Tyson Beckford I was like back
for a dude I gotta tell you something I
wasn't shocked if I had to talk to
somebody that maybe could help me get
this out you know looking for a name
that could do that and and it's just you
know I told him all this he it was like
for him it was like what you said you
just saw Bigfoot you know just what I
don't believe this you know let me ask
you but I don't I understand it for him
you know for people at home nobody I'm
these are I want you to explain to the
people in Ohio yeah what this [__]
thing is from day one
you get reefer is it 80 reefer there's a
strong reefer is it just reefer that the
wheat stores don't want that sell to you
you have an extraction machine how do we
get CBD oil let's start from scratch I
don't know hey I'm learning all the time
okay because there's a lot of there's a
lot of different Focus crap out there
right right I know this much you get
anything that has sugar in it or it's
made they use chemicals to extract or
there's alcohol in it right there I can
guarantee you there are going to be some
compounds that aren't going to be in
that CBD oil or it's not going to have
the same kind of effect plus what if the
person's an epileptic or has seizures
because they need this you know the
sugar kind of thing you can't give them
something with sugar you want something
with glycerin so you don't even affect
that stuff that was yours all right we
have glycerin and we cold press this
stuff it takes us a year to process this
stuff we're lucky to get 30 gallons a
year we're we're dedicated to making it
proper we do the best job that we can uh
I'm I'm I'm super focused on making sure
that this stuff gets out to the public
in every single aspect I'm not going to
run away I know that I'm doing a good
thing uh
you know I just seen so many good things
the autistic children reacting
differently uh PTSD people I got some
PTSD and this stuff really helped me to
really bring some stuff down and calm
down I can say sorry when I don't want
to say sorry stuff like that you know
it's it's amazing it helps me reroute my
my uh cerebral my my brain helped it
helps me to get around things that were
triggering me before and be able to sit
with it without reacting to it and when
that happens a neurological pathway is
formed it helps me go around the trauma
that would normally trigger me to flip
it gets me around to the other side and
gets me connected to the other side what
happens now is there's a pathway built
next time I come across some freak
accident trip that blows my mind the
route is easier for me to get to to get
around without even being there even if
I got the oil or not it I don't have to
keep taking it I'm not hooked to it it
just helped me get my route there that's
all this stuff is this stuff is amazing
we we're the only guys that that the VA
is even considering using like weed for
warriors came out this was going to
happen with us we almost got this deal
going through with these guys we run it
I can only imagine what a what a blast
and what this stuff could do for
someone's mind okay now let me ask you
this the VA is already considering using
the cbdos or they're using they're
considering right now they want to use
it and we're one of the guys that
they're considering to use you know I'm
I'm proud of this product I'm really
proud of what it does you know like
the reason why you're on the show is
because I could tell how proud you are
I'm super proud and I wanted you to
break this [__] down to these
[__] not
you know how your product is better than
the other products
break down I know your product is great
beautiful thing man if you can get any
form I don't know how the other guys are
working but get it and you'll notice
some things like what should have
happened like let's say it doesn't have
glycerin in it what do I want to look
for oh if I don't want sugar I don't
want sugar in my CBD oil no sugar I
don't want sugar in there I don't want
alcohol in there for sure too there's
there's two chemical compounds that I
can see that we have in this stuff here
one of them cbda at 6.27 of this stuff
and the other part is cbga which is
21.69 of this stuff then we've got the
CBD which is only 1.2
1.220 percent
um and D9 THC which is 6.75 the thca is
64.1 there's there's two chemical
compounds you're not going to find using
those others uh uh type of things in
there or you're going to get a really
small small amount where it's not really
you're not going to get that effect I
believe that these two chemical
compounds I don't know why I'm I'm just
going for my own assumption for my
taking this stuff when I hurt my back
and I heard it all the time because I
don't like to lose I keep trying and Jiu
Jitsu just [__] it we're at War bring it
you know so this stuff maybe I get a
Sprint or something like that I noticed
that taking this oil the inflammation
that pain within 90 to like two minutes
this stuff is gone if not gone it's
almost gone and if I wiggle my hips
around and try to relax and stuff my
body knows what's up it releases well I
gotta be honest you gave me a bottle you
gave me two bottles yeah and it sat in
my thing for three or four days you know
I I went online I looked up your company
I uh thought about what my friends said
to me you know
and I I took it as preventive medication
you know
now
you know I'm 100 pounds overweight from
my body frame
uh my right knee has had surgery on it
and I [__] it up right off the bat the
left knee's Tip Top my glue knock on
wood my shoulders give me a little pain
from doing behind the neck things and
you know guys it's like my friend Timmy
gets in and out of a truck all [__]
day you know he doesn't have a broken
ankle but in the winter and all that
stuff your body gets sore okay no no
this is what I was thinking about so
what the [__] do you guys want me to
tell you at home this is what I did I
did exactly what these guys do Leo
drinks a smoothie for breakfast he's a
vegan
so I started putting [__] almond milk
with the cherries like he Leo told me I
started drinking my smoothie in the
morning and then I uh spray the uh
stupid [__] in my [__] nose the
whatever the lower the inflammation
steroids
and then I blast you know you told me
you said listen your body's used to it
already it calls for three drops so I
put maybe six drops in there okay now
what what do you guys want me to tell
you my dick got harder so they could see
through walls I will tell you what I
felt differently
I felt a little bit more energetic in
the mornings than I usually do I felt
myself thinking a little clearer now I
didn't take anything off the only other
supplement I take beside this is my
protein shake the Hem force and I take
the protein after drink I get
that my friend's company makes it's low
sugars and all that [__] and I could
take a baby aspirin and that's it and I
take six drops of this now let me tell
you guys what I've encountered I'm a fat
[__] when the Judo guy came to town
usually I wouldn't go I don't want to
get flipped when you're heavy it doesn't
feel good to get flipped there's a lot
of pressure in one drop I know how to
fall I went to aikido as a kid I went to
you know now you learn how to break
Falls I went to the Jujitsu the Judo one
and they pick your ankle up Lee and
throw you up in the air and you land it
was tremendous I can't lie to you they
were starting from the feet and you do
the whole thing no flips no crazy 69s
and all that [__] just a a leg toss you
know
I gotta tell you something I woke up the
next day
and I didn't feel dick
okay I got a little pain in my wrist
I don't have that much pain anymore if
you want me to tell you that my knee is
healed I can't say that then that's a
torn [__] meniscus in there and God
knows what else is in there but that
little ache I would get in there from
time to time which was a little bit of
arthritis
is gone
I could feel the tendon I'm no [__]
Gene I'm not gonna tell you that the CBD
oilfield attendant I'm not blind anymore
that's when people are not going to buy
into it but when
I read the amount of people going to
Colorado for their children
when I read about uh people taking it
for PTSD somebody got arrested two years
ago because they got it shipped to their
house and but the guy said he didn't
hear voices anymore he's still a little
[__] up but he didn't hear voices
if it keeps you together I have heard
phenomenal results with cancer
phenomenal results with cancer in fact
they even said that the Edibles with the
marijuana it was kind of bad for you
because of the sugar that they'd much
rather you have the kaniba oil however
the [__] you said I'm not going to say
it right
I don't [__] bro I [__] it up too so
whatever I don't talk about this with
you people because I I know there's a
lot of states that are listening to this
or a lot of countries and you don't know
that this exists or this is available to
you you do know but you don't want to
know about it I'll tell you what you
know in my 30 days that's what I felt
but I
excuse me I felt something else
sleep better
I've been hitting a certain Realm
REM sleeping REM sleep because I've been
dreaming I had a dream I went back to
Cuba with a bunch of these [__]
and I lost a milli bra but I lost
everybody but Becky kept [__] you
know I couldn't get she's like the flu
well
how much do both of you because you used
to Joey did you get any uh Kickback
because I know if I told my mom
who grew up in the 60s and 70s
that I was using marijuana medically
she'd laugh or say or or get be very
skeptical about it because all they
think of it as Reefer Madness is a drug
so how much of a kickback I mean have
you either of you guys gone KitKat what
do you mean like like just people being
like Oh that's that's uh snake oil or
that's that's not real or oh I I have
I've heard a little bit but not as much
as I was expecting I got a lot of people
more they don't want it because it's
drugs
right you know that thing but not so
much snake oil but because it's drugs it
I can't do it no I lost one of my best
friends in Eddie Solomon he actually was
a a semi kind of new like a uh Dana
White would give him a couple shirts for
his fights and had a big bull symbol for
it and all that and uh and we try to get
him on this stuff he spent like 750 000
chasing the world doing different chemos
all over the place and it wasn't working
and then you know he just went down you
know
uh that to me was like whoa you know I
read a case
I read a case where
and guys I'm no medical [__] Journal
I'm just here to describe what I read to
you I read a case where they did
something not came out
to lower the tumors
the tumors went down oh and with the CBD
oil yeah no no he did something
completely different not chemo some
other type of radiation some other type
of it's the same [__] [__] ain't that
radio you shouldn't came up he did
something else that went down this is a
case like an England or some [__]
and then the
he went on the CBD oil no here's the
deal he did it it came back he did three
different treatments the doctor didn't
work from his sister suggested CBD oil
he did the CB [__] d-oil after all
that stuff the things went away and
never came back he's cancer-free three
in the [__] half years okay that's
not a snake oil [__] school that's
nice they even went they they talked
about the laboratory they got it from
and the lab broke it down we're about to
get a call from Chris's partner and he's
got more of the facts about science and
stuff like that you know uh
these are the things I have read like I
said I have a friend DG
and he lives in Colorado whatever the
[__] and we were talking about a month
ago or whatever he was telling me the
amount of prices and how they've gone up
but he goes you know a lot of these
people are into something
because their kids either get epileptic
fits or there was something else this
was no cancer involved here this was
where the kids don't get fits no more
the kids are focusing better in school
you know one thing I noticed was beside
the Sleep the sleep on my end was very
good I was getting solid asleep and I
was getting seven hours a night but what
I forgot to tell you guys was also a
sense of calmness Lee yesterday I gave
somebody a ride home out of the kindness
in my heart and they drove me into an
alley that was bumper to bumper traffic
and the only one car moved every 10
minutes here I got my luggage in the
[__] car I wanted to turn around and
punch him right in the [__] mouth
because he lives on this block you
should know this [__] road
construction on a Sunday but I gotta
tell you I wasn't even mad at all
like it didn't bother me like little
things I was Madeline attribute that to
the CBD oil
I have a sense of calmness
and I don't know what that calmness is
from and don't get me wrong I'm still
[__] animal I'm still a degenerate
but uh these are the things I noticed
whenever you work out Lee okay you're a
big guy you're a strong guy whenever
Chris works out I get on top of Chris
I'm 300 pounds okay Chris isn't bench
pressing me
but he's moving around uh Jiu Jitsu all
that stuff kettlebells is anaerobic
okay so yeah you focus
on those big muscles if I if I tear a
bicep God forbid it hurts if I tear if
something it hurts but every time you
work out you tear Little Fibers you take
Little Fibers around your [__] joints
you know stuff that you don't feel you
don't [__] know
you know
I think this helps
I think this helps your joints
I think this helps a little bit with
arthritis we were talking about my
friend's dad that his mother said it
didn't work in her hands but the father
doesn't use a walking stick no more
she's he only eats a little piece of
achievement you just a little piece
before he takes a [__] Hank
so these are the things I [__] heard
do I believe in all this [__] yes and no
yes and no somebody's lying
somebody's [__] lying or somebody's
not approving this for a [__] reason
well
um I I I saw something recently uh where
a doctor was breaking down that when
um you know he was he was just coming
clean about it saying like uh when
doctors do the chemo stuff they actually
get a kickback and they make some money
there you know of course they probably
pick a certain kind of chemo well the
insurances they bill you 82 000 even
though it's only really ten thousand
dollars well you get a percentage of
that if you're a doctor at the end of
the year you get a bonus from those
companies you know whether it's uh pills
you prescribe it's money based you know
I got six pills to prescribe to you and
you come into my office but I prescribe
you one if I prescribe that pill to four
out of my ten patients I come in with
anxiety problems I'm getting a bonus
from them at the end of the [__] year
if I convince Lee who's a doctor to do
the same [__] thing and Chris did do
it that's the way a political system
works that's part of our politics
them giving it away
you know let me explain something to you
how long does a [__] commercial last
for a drug Chantix 30 to 60 seconds bro
no no how long how long do they play
them for you ever see how they play them
in blocks but they play them in blocks
for 90 days you might see them a lot I
guarantee that's the end of the year
rush for them and doctors are giving
that [__] out like hotcakes when you
come into a doctor the doctor will say
listen there's a generic pill that's 32
dollars but this is way better I'm going
to give you a sample of this
what do you want to eat the generic [__]
but you won't eat the good [__] so it
gives you a little [__] taste it's
like it's like dealing Coke it's like
sealing wheat yeah take this butt I'm
gonna call you now if it's [__] good
nobody wants to do God's pill they want
the good pills so they get bonuses based
on that stuff
and then the price of cannabis even with
a markup and I grew up in Boulder
so I was introduced to holistic medicine
in Boulder
could I jump up and down over it no but
I knew a lot of people that took care of
a lot of problems I have I have bursitis
on my feet I went for that [__] where
they [__] drained the bag out of your
foot you want to talk about pain let me
kick in the nut sack Lee that's a
[__] introduction that's nothing when
they stick a needle in your heel pull
that out and then put another Cortisone
shot in your [__] heel and they got
to do both feet both days you know what
I'm saying walking is no fun no no you
can't walk for a day and then they put
the heel no but if you get bursitis you
have no idea with that slight ladies and
gentlemen I'm not trying to hide behind
this thing
if you get bursitis you have a you have
this pain every time you sit down
okay if you ever have it you'll [__]
know you have it in your heel it's from
wearing the wrong shoes or running
without proper support it's like shin
splints it's the opposite of the shin
splints so what happens you're on your
feet Papa everything's great go sit down
and get a pen and call your wife when
you get back up you have no [__] idea
how your heel feels when you get up to
pee in the middle of night you have no
[__] idea when you wake up in the
morning you dread it because you got to
get on that foot so they have to shoot
that foot drain it and put a [__]
Quarters on in there to lower that [__]
and and so you're saying does the we
make that pain go away well I haven't
had it in years
but I'd like to see how all that stuff
affects that and trust me there's study
is going on right now this time just
studies and it's always it's tons of
stuff oh yeah tons of studies you know
all you need is 10 people to come out
and say the tumor is lowered all you
need is 10 people to come out and say
they have chronic arthritis and now they
don't have swelling in their hands
that's all you need we need people to
step up and say it that's all we need
people to make YouTube videos and tell
them
show it yeah and wake the [__] world
up you know what I'm saying I know if I
was doing something and I was getting
the [__] super positive result from
it and I wasn't sharing and I'd feel
like a [__] [__]
I feel like a [__] [__] wait a
second I got a kid that can't you know
and you know what's going on and you
don't say anything you're just as guilty
so that's me man like I I got this uh I
want spiritual wealth I don't need any
other other kind of well spiritual world
to me that's that's where I get it like
being real with this you know like
this is what it's doing for people
I want to make sure people can see it I
want to make sure people can get it I
want people with their children to be
kind of tattoo of weed on you huh you
got a tattoo a week no nothing like that
I mean no you understand you don't come
in with weed shirts you know those
[__] monkeys no I'm not I'm not
cheers
I respect you and Leo a lot I've learned
a lot since I've been going to that
class over there me too nice people
because I look up to those guys in a way
that I don't look up to nobody I don't
give a [__] about these creatures I deal
with in the music industry in the comedy
like I got no [__] respect for them
there's like a handful that you really
like the rest of them you talk to
because you got to talk to these [__]
morons
but
uh I look at the people since I was a
kid man
my mom used to always tell me right out
you're gonna have two choices in life
you can hang out with [__] losers you
can hang out with people that are doing
something
usually those people aren't as
interesting but you learn more from
those [__] people and sometimes I sit
there and I look around that class and I
talk to people and I ask them creepy
[__] questions
you know there's a reason why you're
built that way
what are you doing and they'll say I'm a
vegan or I'm not I can't imagine my life
without a steak but that's out but
nobody can say you could be a half a
vegan well it's half of a half a vegan
leave instead of eating four steaks a
week you eat one
okay do you find what I'm saying and you
eat six ounces with two eggs or
something like that
you know you could be a half a vegan you
know you could eat fish all the time and
you could look at your egg count you
know you could make protein shakes in
the morningly I always made a smoothie
with almond juice and fruit and a little
[__] banana and an hour later guess
what I eliminated those things and I and
at 11 I have a protein shake now
so there's no solid food in me before
lunch no way yeah I'm gonna try to do
that I'm gonna try to do that for the
next [__] six weeks
and then go to Jujitsu at 12 do that
workout then come home
you're gonna have a tremendous meal a
salad a protein hey I got a good I got a
good easy salad for you a little bit of
a carb I don't eat a lot of [__] no no
just keep it simple lettuce tomato
onions maybe an avocado vinegar oil you
made my [__] day right here like easy
stuff like what quinoa oh no no no I've
got an avocado in there all right and
then you get uh kale and you get uh
oh my God I can't get the name of the
plant in in my head yeah you're owing
two already with the kale yeah arugula
arugula oh that's good what the [__]
you got arugula even Steve Martin
couldn't find it in the witness
relocation I don't know you ever see
that movie kept saying I can't get no
arugula
but you can put CBD oils in those shakes
can't you like in the smoothies and
shakes that you do I'd rather put it
directly in my mouth let it get absorbed
like he told me 60 seconds so like it's
like when we eat those Stars Lee okay
let me tell you something my friend I
got no reason to lie to you two guys
yeah that took a I didn't see Anarchy
animals but I took those wacky taffies
to [__] DC with me where the [__] I
was feeling I'm sorry
Thursday night I took that wacky Taffy
and I chewed the [__] out of it like it
owed me 10 bucks and I gotta tell you
something I felt this [__] feeling
within 20 minutes and I got you know
we're family here we [__] ain't 900
milligrams for it that had 200
milligrams
and within 20 minutes I was on fire once
I got on stage Lee I blacked out
like blacked out like it was this
[__] act I told him about my friend
that did Coke and totally a fly on his
forehead
smack us forward interrupt everybody and
go [__] there's a fly on my forehead and
he would smack your forehead I took him
deep into the murky Waters of the
underworld but Friday night I did the
same thing I chewed the [__] out of it
because it's all in your mouth like
that's my point that's why you swallowed
you're a half a fruit kick I cut it in
half you don't have it I can eat two
more chew them down like a [__] nail
like a nickel how you feeling on that
start dog I don't want you to tap out
like oh and benches
[__] you're the [__] Man of Steel
this [__] why yeah pretty much
he was drinking [__] kale and reefer
shakes and three
I had capsules for the first time the
other night they're really good I've
never done them before
they took a little while to kick in but
like have you ever done those you know
why they took a while to kick in because
you have to like melt the capsule no
because that's what I figured that's a
sugar
the star is sugar when you go to a
[__] bar right and you drink like a
[__] gin and tonic okay something
happens but it doesn't get that same
[__] go to go to the Frozen drink
place across the way and get a Bahama
Mama with a hundred and watch what
happens to you because that Sugar goes
right into your oh that's so smart and
next thing you know you're [__] up so
that edible takes longer because it's a
capsule and it's oil next time I'll have
to do it with like a milkshake who the
[__] do you think you're doing at least
I had some [__] novice here that's
why they put sugar in all that [__] ah I
thought it was the mask people say that
if you eat it with cheese it doesn't
work who eats cheese and [__] reefer
anyway people [__] though you don't
wear Pizza that the cheese lasts long I
don't listen to [__] we're eating it'll
last longer even if I eat a [__] tree
I could eat a [__] a rope with fiber
and I'm still [__] up for two days Lee
says he's high in three shits the next
morning what kind of animal are you oh
it's crazy like I'm behind bro
I'll be high sometimes until I work out
like that's why like I'm glad that
sometimes the Kettlebell class is early
because I'll get to the Kettlebell class
so it's not too high to be here I'm
trying to do a Turkish Get Up and I get
scared then I'm gonna drop them weight
on my face because it's like it's a lot
of weight I'm like I'm too high to be
here and then as soon as you start
sweating I'm like okay I'm okay
that's why I never understood he always
used to tell me go in that elliptical hi
I'm like I'm gonna fall off that
elliptical I that that's and that's why
I think it's cool Segway that CBD is
non-psychoactive like it's just it's
it's a natural people see that's the
biggest thing to make people overcome
one big question I have for you because
this is a question my friend had for me
yeah let's pretend I have arthritis hmm
I don't want to do the [__]
medication it makes my [__] [__]
itch you don't want to get all high
right right no you don't want to do none
of that [__] yeah I try the cbdos I'm a
union guy
I got a call I go pee in a cup what
comes back
go back to work
seriously what we got in there isn't
even it's like eating granola with a
hemp seed in it it don't mean nothing it
the the the THC value in here is so low
we're legally allowed to ship this in
all 50 states
there's no issue with that are you
[__] we just got ourselves we
stretched out to Australia we just got
ourselves some some people working over
there now we we want to make sure
everybody knows that we're coming in
we're not playing games
we're gonna do some work here
and do some good things
and feel good about it at the end of the
day about what we're doing I watched a
very interesting documentary I was high
as [__] when I go back to my hotel room
unlike a lot of people they go out and
eat whatever I gotta shut down what I
just went through is how I'm 53 I'm a
fat guy I'm out of shape and I put my
whole soul on the [__] line on stage
I don't want I don't want you to pay 25
bucks and for me to half-ass it
so I don't [__] around at these shows so
I talk to people I do what I can I go
back to my hotel room
I get water I got bugles this Saturday
there's a little bag of bugles I took it
back on my room I'm very satisfied
and I decompress but there was an
interesting show on about acupuncture
about how acupuncture started I believe
a [__] bird half bird half man
in China you know I love this started
acupuncture started acupuncture wait
what half was bird one half of us well
[__] knows he had wings in the hands I
don't [__] know but they saw the same
symbol in India and they saw the same
symbol somewhere else and they believed
that the these people came down these
terrestrials came down and showed them
how to heal people the Chinese bird
would eat a drug that would make them
hallucinate and he could look into your
body that's how he created the the
points for acupuncture what are they
called uh the meridians the meridians
right the channels the meridians that's
how he devised that [__] and they've
even dug up like [__] uh mummies of
these guys of of mummies of whatever the
[__] they came from Egypt Egypt because
it was Egypt
China do they look different India
that's all the same God yeah oh man with
a bird oh yeah with a bird's body so oh
that guy that guy so when they went to
[__] very interesting it was the same
thing in China they found no no they
they had proof now that what that
[__] taught in China they were
doing in [__] uh Egypt because they
dug up a mummy and they had proof that
this [__] was doing acupuncture
not only that that [__] Ching woo
that [__] half bird half man did an
open heart surgery three thousand
[__] years ago before they knew
anything about anything but that claim
to fame was that the skies opened up and
that the the deities came down and
showed them how to heal Mankind and this
is how acupuncture started it [__]
blew my mind then they took it in a
different directions with [__]
martians and [__] and I had to [__]
put on uh
uh
uh Blue Bloods or whatever the [__] I
was watching but the point of the story
is
that I'm a firm believer in acupuncture
I saw what it did to me and what they
were talking about
made me believe what I believe about
acupuncture that you go in there your
Chi is low from throughout the years and
gets worn from stress from pain from
drug abuse weather your Chi that's
that's your that's how the Chinese
believe it's your [__] Inner Strength
what they do with acupuncture that the
Americans don't understand the same
reason why this CBD oil is a tough to
sell he's [__] Americans because
they're affiliated with the
hallucinogenic in it is because it takes
time to build your Chi back
and once you build your CHI with
acupuncture then you become bulletproof
that's when my cat you know my calves
don't swell up after a six hour flight
normal did you know that there's a
exercise that the Chinese are are not
allowed it's like illegal to do and it's
called Uh uh china-san
and um
if you uh look it up and you and you
study it on the internet off of YouTube
it's the simplest thing ever
and um and uh the the benefits out of
the thing are just amazing it's just
self-healing and building your Chi up in
that way
um I kind of like recommend people take
a look at that and I also recommend
taking a look at something called falun
dafa and following dafa's amazing
exercises as well that helped you to
build your Chi real powerful yeah you
can do it from one thing also that's
that's the best [__] way fallen down
for yeah it was amazing all I found off
was just a form of Tai Chi that has just
five exercises that illegal to do in
China
what happens if you do these those
exercises go out of your house and [__]
your cat what do you think but they were
doing there I don't know what they're
doing but all I know is that when I when
I did it and I did it for myself it
really opened up my back and opened up
my neck
freed me up you know
I think the most important thing
that make uh the American uh I think the
most important thing because I see it
with my wife
listen man
my wife really believes in her yoga
I like that my wife believes in her yoga
do I believe in as much as my wife does
no but I'll tell you what man my wife
does handstands she's 46 years old and
[__] does handstands she can put her
legs behind her head she does one-handed
[__] I can't even [__] dream of doing
she's doing a challenge now
you know she's a little embarrassed
about the baby fat that stuck around I
mean she lost all the baby fat except
three pounds when she finishes that
she's even thinking they're going to
Legacy and doing an attack fit because
her friend was talking about attack for
that yoga and it's very interesting you
know the whole [__] thing
but I see her belief in it she doesn't
believe in the [__] Swami Lami and
the [__] guy with the bikini walking
around in the heat she don't fall for
that [__] you know that's [__]
pervert you can't tell that guy is a
Cosby Junior wait till that comes out
that guy [__] lullabies you with
yogurt and [__] in the ass and I'm like
so much you know what I'm saying look
you're sweating yeah cause I just got
[__] in the ass what do you think I'm
sweating and [__]
ah
it's Monday night [__] you know I
mean that's the trip so my wife goes to
that place
it's an hour and a half it's guys men
you know I've gone in there with a I
love it it's no incense it's no [__]
Hindus walking around with dirty [__]
feet no that's just what it's three
white chicks that got their doctorates
one lived in India and they got together
as a business they're female owners they
don't pimp it out they don't have child
care in there they take your phone on
the way in
shut that all down if my wife gives her
an extra attendance as the phone rings
at the daycare
I know when she's there so it's people
believe in certain things and they stick
with it you know I'm a fat [__] I go to
that Jiu Jitsu school I'm not going to
be a world champion no but I'll tell you
what I'm going to lose the most weight
going over there three times a [__]
week I'll prove that to you right now I
know it that my body fat is definitely
down since I joined over there just with
that [__] jacket you gotta wear that
jacket when I bring it home I gotta hang
it outside my knee pad you think I
sucked a thousand [__] in the heat you
think I sucked a thousand dicks in 90
degree weather and [__] my knee pads are
stretch who sweats from their knees I
had to get new knee pads the back of
them smell like [__] a dead armpit
lead they [__] you couldn't I was
scared when people passed my guard that
they could sniff them through the
[__] pants the other guy there's a
bald guy there in class holy [__] one
day I had him on the north south and he
goes Jesus You're Gonna sniff my dirty
knees we were Holland because your knee
pad you have to take them off and leave
them outside and let them get dry and
then put them in the washer it's a
[__] nightmare what was my point I
don't even know what I'm talking about
here uh cbdos that's right back to CBD
laws what time is it Lee
652 all right so we got eight [__]
minutes you're gonna put Tony Bennett on
you're gonna sit there like a mama Luca
here and stuff you mind if I go use a
bathroom okay that's the whole time I'm
sitting here like a fpv yeah
go to your right
what are you gonna do ladies and
gentlemen I'm saying it's Monday night
me and Leon on fire one more storm might
go down
below he's looking a little pale and
[__] over there oh my God Lee you went
[__] pale before
after that first bomb Oh my God your
face got really red and then all the
blood shot from your body what the
eyeballs bolts when was the last time
you had a bong it's been a while right
yeah
late
I don't doesn't matter when the last
time we did a bong I've been telling you
for a month
we're in training I know but I have baby
lungs we might show up with a bong we
might show up with a pipe you got to be
prepared with Uncle Joey you know what
I'm saying you never know what we're
gonna [__] show but the star a
mushroom cap
you throw away those mushrooms
[__] I didn't throw away no more
mushroom but the liquor [__] acid's
still hidden in the Vault of Life yeah
that's what I would have thrown away
how you feeling all right I'm feeling
pretty uh pretty marketed at the moment
good good you're looking [__] pretty
Immaculate yourself too
um yeah no my dad and I had a great time
this weekend I'm happy you you put a
tear to mine last night he looks great
he's getting old we're getting old he's
having a good time but uh we got [__]
super high with him we [__] sent them
[__] packing last night his hair he
was here in [__] Vietnamese people
yelling
jumping through weeds and [__] that weed
was tremendous last night oh my God it
was really good
I'm
he left with some animals
we got some delivery which I've never
done before which is really cool
I've never done that and it was really
fun
um yeah oh
we saw that new Independence Day which
was pretty terrible I know that when you
when you told me what it is like we saw
the first one though this week going
back to this old school things again it
was a double feature the original it was
so good a double feature of [__] that
they hit you with the first it's like
going on a date she lets you suck her
titties you drop 200 and then she tells
you you got to go home because her
brother sleeps on the bed yeah that's
what happened to [__] you when you
went over to see that dumbass [__]
movie you could tell that was bad in the
commercial you're like oh they [__] up
they [__] up did they win a million
dollars did they win number one uh I'm
sure stupid we [__] are As Americans
oh no and and then you wonder why Isis
[__] is going to shoot you in the
[__] head because you go see
Independence Day you gotta boycott that
[__] those Marvel movies it's over we're
looking for one [__] hero an American
hero you want to go see Independence Day
like a [__] bunch of moocs okay well
what here I know that you're gonna think
I'm crazy but I had this thought that
they should just stop making new movies
and start re-releasing because you
always you always give me [__] for not
seeing this and that and it's because it
came out before my time I think they
have enough good movies now that they
could re-release those
and as they are yeah we release them
with a new cast you know what and I
thought about that's a very interesting
question that you brought up because my
dad and I we watched uh airplane which
I'd never seen before we watched Coming
to America we watched trains everything
coming to America I ain't seen that one
but I watched it too this week oh my God
those movies they stand up dude they
look a little bit it's not HD it's it's
not
I don't think there's actors that can
man that could hold up what would you
rather do HD or a [__] good movie
great movies okay then what the [__] I
don't wanna I don't give two [__] about
HD [__] no
I was watching Coming to America you
could see the makeup yeah and I had a
regular TV in the hotel room
you can see the [__] makeup yeah
that's what I can see with HD that's all
I could see how old the movies really
are but the movies are solid [__]
movie oh my God [__] airplane are you
serious are you [__] serious have you
ever seen a grown man naked it never
it's all a bunch of dumb is that the one
with OJ now no it's on with Kareem he's
the co-pilot that's right that's right
that's right that's right but it's and
okay I understand that it's it's very
far-fetched and and my thought was that
the stars now could have have access to
the camera yeah
forget your [__] iTunes who's gonna
play
Charles Bronson and Death Wish okay no
one give me 30 seconds I'll give you 60
seconds oh death please
please let him keep smacking the [__]
oh yeah no yeah
okay because of that that's just a joke
you know I'm just [__] around here
I'm trying to think I'm trying to think
like
uh
yeah Godly maybe Liam Neeson Javier oh
come on guys yeah
no no no no no not that lurchy
[__]
that's a wish right now if I had a
[__] cast it
death wish
the problem with death wishes
if you really watch death wish
the problem is he sold the old the
architect
but has phased it
uh go ahead put on a piece of Death Wish
just any piece
one of the most disgusting [__]
disturbing rape scenes I have ever
[__] seen in my life I was a young
kid yeah yeah yeah I left that movie
theater [__] mummified that it was go
Bloom is one of the [__] robbers in
that movie [__] and that white dude
that's still around the only thing
scared me back then was to see in the
alien movie oh [__] this made the alien
movie look like a [__] tic-tac-toe
game I mean this is [__] rough when
you're a child you don't know about that
well you know that that came out like 70
73 I was 10. okay you know I was eight I
was just born
okay let me see uh this is what so this
is what the [__] Death Wish rape
scene
[Laughter]
just go up go out door go up to the
beginning just right right there where's
this muggers go ahead oh God this is
after his wife gets raped and he just
starts going in the [__] Street crazy
all right he just says [__] this now
here's a guy that's supposed to be a
[__] architect but like I'm saying to
you guys he's got a face not of a killer
but of a weathered man
who the [__] is gonna play Charles
Bronson
the other thing about Charles Bronson
was he was 50 when he did these Antonio
Banderas no he was 50 when he did these
and he was in good shape
he was a phenomenal [__] shape
so who the [__] is gonna play this this
is my question they picked the director
they announced this and that and this
and that they're really trying to break
my [__] heart but I'm not breaking
sticks and stones will break my bones I
won't watch it and they're doing a
second part to a mechanic which never
[__] existed how can you do a sequel
to a movie that never [__] existed
look at him does he look like a [__]
architect to you
I want to watch this [__] go down oh
yeah yeah
he's like we're out of here
now this is that I don't know guys and
you're looking at me you're saying
listening to me going Joey this guy this
guy this guy
I don't see nobody else [__] playing
this right now man
Richard Gere is too old
Andy Garcia
might be able to pull this off
I can see Andy Garcia
not the dude from [__] that show on
Showtime the [__] dude that fixes
things nah nah
nah not now now none of those dudes run
through my [__] mind right now
and that's my point like yeah maybe
someone could play it but we already
have this
so just lower the ticket prices
let families go to movies again and
re-release watch this
put the [__] thing on put the mic on
so people can hear it the guy just
ripped his paper Charles Grossman shoots
him shoots this [__] hump
shoots him again shoots this [__]
again and he's off the train it's 1973
there's no [__] cameras they're not
going to be able to do this [__]
scene Momos because this [__] cameras
everywhere unless they make a timepiece
and everything
listen to the music listen to what's
going through his mind
see he's out of there that's it he's out
of there the cop they don't you cannot
suspect this guy
this was a brilliant film because of
this look he's gone nobody knows nothing
there's no camera not one piece of
dialogue nothing no there's always that
was the 70s they made you have
imagination and they're not made you
have imagination there you go where'd
the cops go the completely other way see
if there's another scene that's why
that's that's why I like the first alien
they didn't have all that special
effects they made you have to [__]
they mean you have to like imagine that
[__] while I was in the shop take it
look it up
what's happening Brother Joey Diaz here
good you got to speak up a little bit
down there you gotta speak into the mic
please how are you down there in Hawaii
I'm doing all right how about yourself
not bad which I'm happy you called uh
you know we were just talking about the
whole process of CBD
uh how the process works you know how
your product is processed compared to
the other products on the market and the
case studies that you've heard about or
things you've heard about you know
course
so yeah so what it what what scientific
what scientific uh studies or
information do you have regarding your
CBD
well the CBD that we have at the moment
is completely different than most
people's CBD out there on the market
it's um it's a cold press process
and it takes over a year to make the oil
it's not
um it's not made with the butane or the
CO2 it's not made for the quick buck
the person who's doing it
actually has really good intentions and
started off that way and continues to um
roll down that path
so uh it seems like the really good
stuff takes a lot longer to make than
than the average product let's say that
now one question what would happen to me
if I did do a CBD oil
with the CO2 process what's the
difference what's going on there
um you know what I believe they're all
very beneficial
depending on what your Affliction is
I've seen a lot of different oils from
the CO2 extraction
uh to the RSO all the different oils
seem to affect different people in
different ways and a lot are very
positive
um I personally have a belief just from
what I've been witnessing that it's more
about the whole plant
compounds
it seems that um
all the compounds are already in the
plant and when you start doing processes
to it you start to eliminate a lot of
the important compounds in there that
are very medicinal to the body
now where does the hallucinogenic part
of it go when you do that
um if if it's done correctly uh
the CBD oil is non-psychotropic and it
is not hallucinogenic whatsoever
um when you when you take
marijuana or CBD and you heat it up once
it hits its molting point at 180 degrees
it decarbonates
it decarbalizes and it becomes
psychotropic and becomes activated and
now you actually get high from it
so as long as you can keep it if you can
keep your process
it's the right temperatures you can keep
your compounds from activating and they
stay medicinal and they won't get you
high but but that being said I have seen
a lot of people go through a euphoric
moment when they take the product
and they almost for a second would think
they're high but I tend to believe now
the more I watch it that they're feeling
good and they re they don't remember
what it's like to feel good all the time
so euphoric is a good thing
now what ailments have you heard that
this
CBD oil your product is effective on
you know what it's been effective on
just about everything it's a very broad
spectrum oil
um I personally don't make it it's made
in Colorado I just seem to have been the
lucky guy to have met up with this
person
and um
it being very broad spectrum because it
has all the compounds in it it's it's a
dietary supplement in a sense where it
allows your body
to take over and to use the compounds in
it that it needs to Aid your immune
system to fight cancer to
keep the anti-inflammatories
anti-anti Caesar all of that stuff it
seems that your body can can weed
through the compounds itself and use the
ones it needs and dispense the ones it
does not
and considering that other products out
there
I don't like to talk bad about products
um this is the least invasive thing I've
come across in my life
that is very beneficial
well uh how what would you say how it
works with uh with uh like say opioid
abuse
amazing actually
um I have a I have an amazing story I
have a doctor that
um
he himself was on opioids he is a what I
would call a pill farmer and um
I gave him the oil because I live in
pain myself I was there for my own pills
and my own problems and afflictions and
I offered him the oil and he took a dose
his phone rang
and I said you're gonna get that and he
said no that's my phone saying take my
pill and I said you're not going to take
your pill and it had only been two
minutes and he said I don't have the
desire to take the pill for the first
time in years
so I've seen it work that quick and that
was an MD
and he at the moment is prescribing it
to people to get off of their opioids
because it seems to have a very uh
positive effect on the opioid receptors
it seems to stop the pain enough
to allow your body to say I don't really
want that pill
then your mind has to deal with you know
whether you want it or not
um and I'm sure the pharmaceutical
companies don't want to hear that CBD
oil does that stuff
in my little study that uh the bottles
Chris gave me in my little study I found
that
I was sleeping a little deeper
I uh I've always been an erotic sleeper
I have sleep apnea
but if I get five hours I'm pretty good
but I gotta get up one time to pee ever
since I've been doing the CBD oil in the
morning
I get up to pee one time but it's a
tough walk
and when I go back to bed I go right
back to bed and I'm having dreams again
like vivid dreams nothing sexual just
going to Cuba going to Jujitsu going to
a park [__] like that and they always
did the good stuff yeah and I've also
realized that
those look you know like I was
explaining to Chris I have a rip
meniscus I'm not going to tell you that
the CBD oil took away the pain but I'll
tell you what it did take a little bit
of pain away from that little arthritis
pain
you know I'm a 300 pound guy so every
time I go on my wrist I re-heard it but
I don't have that constant little pain
for an hour after jiu jitsu too
gotcha well let me explain to you um
just from you you saying that you do
only in morning dose uh if you were to
up the dose
um that this oil is a saturation game
this particular product it's like taking
an antibiotic it has to Loop through
your system to hit all the organs and to
get all the way up into your to cross
the blood-brain barrier and could really
really get into you
um I call it the saturation point and um
if you were to actually up your dosage
not more drops but just more times per
day I bet you that evening you have a
longer block of sleep and most likely
about a week or two in I bet you would
notice that you would have less frequent
um
yearning to go to the bathroom in the
middle of the night well like I said I'm
I used to be a three or night peer
and now it's one good P about 4 30 which
means I got four and a half good maybe
five hours of sleep
it used to be 12 and I'd be [__]
walking around at 12 o'clock at two
o'clock I'm sorry which you don't do
dick in two hours it's like it's like
you know so now I feel like I've been
sleeping a little deeper uh today I
slept till seven in the morning why
because when I got off the plane I
blasted that stuff
yeah well I have I have um amazingly
elderly people like I have an 87 year
old lady she takes one drop and she just
have to eat meds so the tumor in her
spine and she gets 10 hour blocks of
sleep I see the stuff do so many
different things to so many different
people that it's so all over the board
um I at the moment if I could show you
pictures I would um I have little kids
um with cerebral palsy that are 82 days
in at the moment without having a
seizure and they haven't been on meds
now for 82 days post all that stuff on
my wall so I can show everybody huh
yeah it's these are some amazing Stories
um the the lady is on the East Coast
with the two kids and I actually wasn't
very uh knowledgeable in CP at all in
the first pictures he sent me the little
kid was holding herself up on a table
and she was so excited and I said to her
is this a big deal and she said yeah my
kids can't even sit up and um as you
watch the pictures on on the wall come
in you'll see that she goes from
pulling herself up to walking crawling
now she's talking she's got core
strength They're laughing they look like
little kids and since I guess the
teachers see them the most they their
cognitive skills and everything have
improved so much that the reports coming
back to the mom and she knows the most
because she's the biggest fan and
cheerleader is um
it's undeniable we gave these two little
girls their lives back
and that's just one little story uh of
of a lot of good ones that are going on
at the moment with this product
I'm happy you called in and broke it
down a little bit
further I wanted that end of it also
like I said you know uh
I I went to college in Boulder and uh I
got into different homeopathic stuff I
had bursitis on my heel and
shin splints and that was the beginning
of my shoulder pain and I went to see
different people and I noticed that you
really have to how that process works is
it all starts with belief
and I've been an acupuncture guy now for
nine years
uh twice a month you know and you're
right it's the saturation process we
were just talking about that before with
acupuncture you got to build your Chi up
and then it starts healing and and it
starts working as preventive
so I felt the same way about this I knew
it was going to take a while to saturate
into my body I mean I eat a lot of
marijuana every day there's got to be a
couple CBDs already in there floating
around
but this is the good stuff and uh I wish
you a lot of luck with it and I love
what you're doing
and uh I wish you good luck with the VA
if this is really working
on PTSD and uh
all those little brain seizures and
whatnot this is a this is a great
product
it is a great product I I thank you for
having me and um I look forward to the
world getting a chance at it it is
pricey because we're in the infancy of
this this whole industry at the moment
and there's a lot of convoluted
information out there about how much it
costs to make and this and that but I
believe in the near future it's going to
be very accessible and uh hopefully the
big Pharma and mess it up and take away
the real stuff somehow
um
but I'm glad you got to try it all right
well thank you for your time my brother
good luck to you and if I remember in
Hawaii I'm coming to see you you know
what I always hear your show you just
keep up the good work you're awesome so
are you my brother thank you for calling
in okay Aloha from Hawaii Aloha my
brother yeah bogey
cheers yeah no I'm uh like I said I I'm
enjoying it
I think I'm basically enjoying the
calmness of it you know when you land on
a [__] plane
the [__] Airport's never ready you
understand me
in the old days you're playing lands
they always got a game for you now you
got to wait then you get then they got
to tow it in because the Chinese dude
made a left turn now I gotta wait for
the [__] thing to touch the gate now
the computer broke down they can't open
it yet you know that happened to me
twice in two [__] weeks by the way
but you know what
and lose my cool
because I know what are you going to do
what am I going to do you have some
bottles I can leave around the office
just in case there's nothing just in
case I tell them I went and got hummus
or something
an emergency bottle
no I'm happy you came I I really wanted
to talk about this on this show
I wanted to talk about the pros and cons
I had heard listen guys if you think I'm
gonna make a bunch of [__] copies and
come in here with paperwork you're crazy
I'm gonna tell you what I read now do I
believe what you read half of it but
listen I lived in Colorado for a long
time I got a lot of friends still there
in Boulder and Denver
and I hear the chitter chatter and even
they can't believe it they can't believe
the amount of people they're moving in
with all different types of ailments
and these things work miracles [__]
miracles so who's lying who the [__]
lying they got they got to be doing case
studies at the University of Colorado in
Boulder I know those [__] people
they're cynical I just wonder like how
long have they known and for how long
haven't they told us because man they've
been making some money over here well
they know but the problem is we have
this problem in America right now follow
like peoples we're trying to legalize it
and that pisses some of Americans off so
guess what happens CBD falls into that
[__] Circle why because it's
ignorance why
because of ignorance listen if you think
I'd sit here if you think I would be
here 10 years ago talking to you about
this you got [__] problems yeah 10
years ago I would look at you like a
[__] Coupe all right yeah whatever
great that's it that bottle you gave me
and [__] give it to some poor so yeah
take this drink this little whiskey yeah
now because I've heard all the [__]
positive effects I I I welcomed you I
wanted to hear more about it I'm like
really man and then Leo you know I
believe if Leo tells me he walks on
calls for Anthony Robbins I'll do it
even after the people got burnt those
[__] morons you gotta wear sandals
you know what I'm saying Leo's awesome I
believe anything Leo tells me I look at
this guy I see how he lives I know he
suffers from anxiety he's told me he has
the same anxiety I have there's times
before he goes to class he wants to make
a U-turn and leaves you know uh
and he's very calm he always looks like
he's in a great place when he's there
yeah so I look at guys like this and I
get little tips from them you ask them
what's going on in your world you know
I'm surprised how many people there are
involved
in some sort of marijuana which really
impresses the [__] out of me because I
look at these people and I don't look at
any of those people with stoners
there's not a person there that looks
like a [__] stoner
and sometimes you're rolling them or
they teach you a move well you don't
look like a stoner oh yes I [__] do I
look like I got hit with 2 000 rocks
they just smell me
they just smell me they know
I don't care
look at me bro I look like I hit with 2
000 [__] rocks on the ugly stick what
do you mean I'm a good boy yeah but when
I think Stoners
now you gotta break that round but it
it's really artistic on it man helps me
get real I went to one place where
nobody ever talked about round one
it was like nobody ever mentioned it was
on time two places I went to nobody
talked about there was one place I went
to where people talked about it
but that's it
this place I go to now
nobody looks like there's no bun you got
to see the people how they're built
there
you know there's maybe three or five
people four or five [__] guys that
make him move and the people who have
stayed there those guys get in shape
you just got to keep [__] going we're
that one Mexican guy got about his size
that moves like the wind oh Jesus Christ
oh my God that guy's a [__] killer
he's all over my back we start off I'm
looking in and everything like five
seconds he's on my back he's trying to
shovel me this way he's on my back this
way he's pushing me that way he's
totally yeah and it's not like he's just
for a quick burst it's for like till the
Bell stops you know the whole time he's
moving on you and then he stops and even
breathing that heavy he's just looking
at you he just looks like he was a bear
like that's fine let's do it again you
know you read you see you see ads in the
paper
you see commercials on television for uh
to lose weight fast you know with frozen
food plans and you see all this
advertising media they throw at you
correct as an American that's what you
[__] see you see a ton of it getting
thrown at you and half of us are either
overweight or obese and we're all
looking for the answer listen
everybody wants to eat that [__]
cheesecake after dinner you know at that
birthday celebration nobody wants to go
to a birthday party another [__]
piece of cake you know absolutely they
have bad Pizza you know that bad kid
Pizza people getting out you know how
bad that this video you always eat a
slice at those breakfast yes
well how crazy is advertising if I see a
color of a sign I'll know what fast food
place it is or restaurant it is we all
know logos oh remember White Stripes
uh maybe in and out okay I see
okay okay well KFC's the one the fattest
thing I couldn't even do KFC
anyways that you look at all these
things they throw at your magazine
articles when you sit there going maybe
they're airbrushed maybe they're not
airbrush
when I go to this place
I see the transformation in people's
bodies in six or seven weeks I see how
they change and that's how I know this
works you see the geese looking a little
looser and [__] because it shrinks you
and everywhere at once inch by [__]
inch it shrinks you so it's pretty
impressive you know how you see all
these fake ads 20 minutes a day is all
you [__] need no you don't know that
shit's not gonna [__] work out for
you at all though 20 minutes a day ain't
gonna do nothing for nobody on the
[__] stand Master first off you can't
do it seven [__] days a week till
your legs fall off like poorly one day
Lee's gonna be walking is gonna get the
sharp pain this and he's gonna go what
the [__] is that the Stem Master at time
for a year straight when I [__] told
you to get off that goddamn thing I know
I mean I only do like once a week now
it's uh that's all you need you do those
kettlebells three [__] times a week
you're swinging double kettlebells why
aren't you coming to jiu jitsu with us I
used to go with me at the other place
you gotta come over this school you'd
love this he even went to a competition
and everything did you do a comp did you
do a cop I did not I I was there and I
got destroyed but I I'm really enjoying
though that's still sick
yeah me too man I'm scared I don't want
no one breaking me I want to surf it was
fun it was the most fun I had at Jiu
Jitsu but I
people don't like everything in life you
know that's what makes life [__]
interesting that not everybody likes
[__] Pizza
you know not everybody likes Pizza the
best pizza in the world some people
looking good it's not really me I really
have macaroni and cheese or bacon bits
okay
I just love sharpening the blades that
we have in that class man I love working
out with those guys I like to see them
get better I like to get all weird and
do strange things that they don't know
what the hell is going on and have them
find ways out of it and they're awesome
in the Jiu-Jitsu world yeah when you've
talked to people about this or you've
spoken to the other classmates about
this what are their results from taking
this what do you hear that they say to
you what's the most beneficial thing
back pain back pain is awesome for the
for a lot of my my friends that have
that that like any kind of like you know
that when you when you work out real
hard then your bar is just stiff and
sore and the next day you don't want to
go you know just tired well this kind of
helps you like get that recovery I think
it helps with recovery because it's such
a super anti-uh as a super uh white set
white blood cell booster you know like
it just boosts your white blood cells so
I have a feeling what it does is it
helps you heal up a little faster you
know from stuff I don't get I don't get
as sick as I used to so I can keep
coming to class A lot more my my if I
get Cuts or abrasions or anything like
that I broke my toe pretty good A little
while ago that thing healed up pretty
good
um
this this Jiu Jitsu game has been like a
plus and have have my body there to be
able to do it's like the ultimate you
know to be at the top level that I can
be in that class you know
I'm not young I'm 43 but I'm going
against Leo and once in a while I can
take him that feels really to me it's a
heavy duty accomplishment because Leo's
no joke and nobody in there is any joke
and if I can hassle them somehow I feel
great about it you know at the age that
I'm at you know one thing I know for a
fact
and I've heard of some people that are
anti-marijuana an Australian friend of
mine I have hates this [__] yeah and
he's one of the top trainers in the game
he trains Pacquiao he was Pacquiao
straight strength and fitness coach for
years and they had a disagreement he
opened up his own gym and then towards
the end Pacquiao
hire them back and Pacquiao had them for
the last three or four fights no his
name is adios I call him the Australian
Justin Fortune he owns fortunes gym in
Hollywood between Curson and uh Gardner
it's it's behind you have to go behind
the [__] place there's a coffee shop
in front
it's next to a place that makes
smoothies yeah sure he doesn't go to
Wild Card no more yeah now he goes to
walk hard to train him but he still has
his gym okay okay so the point being
that he despised the [__]
he despised it but one day when him and
I were having a conversation
and him like came to the same agreement
he goes for starters Bruce Lee ate this
[__]
30 years ago and he ate it for a reason
because he knew it took the acid out of
your body and it cleaned out the
infamous inflammation
he doesn't I know for he goes I don't
know smoking that [__]
you know takes does it but I know eating
it does
we just and this is a guy that you know
is anti-refa when me and nakafoli got
arrested Soul would talk about it he
goes what the [__] you bloody Fool's
talking about that marijuana [__] but
you know what he got cancer
and
he went on the Edibles and today he's
alive
because he got an appetite
he lost weight he lost a bunch of weight
so
I'm not gonna sit there in my world and
tell you that
when I smoke marijuana
it's because the headaches I get of the
Martians I see and [__] like that I
would love to be able to tell you that
but I do know one thing when I was
when I go into prison
I had been smoking pot
at that time
Maybe
let's say when I was 25 I started
smoking when I was 12.
so that was half my life at the age of
25 but at one point I smoked it
recreationally correct from uh
seventh grade to maybe
junior year in high school I smoked it
recreationally I smoked it to get high
and listened to records and think at
night like I was [__] Copernicus
whoever the [__] I thought I was but
then it came to a point where I realized
that I needed marijuana to sleep
I never liked those Valiums even though
I took them from time to time I didn't
like how I felt in the morning
but I didn't mind how marijuana made me
feel in the morning and in those days in
the in 82 and 83 I got to be honest with
you guys
I was getting some Superman Reef in New
York at the time what year this is 82 83
84 and 85. I'm telling you that I was I
wouldn't lie to you first off
but when I was a sophomore in high
school there was a guy his name was
Pullman that was he was a teacher's name
he was one of those cool hipsters
already he was cool in everybody else
and he ran the department where they
built the stages and if you did his
class you hung out
the whole day except for twice a year
where you built the stage of Jesus
Christ Superstar and in the summer you
built this crack for The Nutcracker
Suite or whatever the [__] it was but
Bob Pullman's claimed the fame was that
he lived in Hawaii in the summer that's
what made him cool
he was a jersey guy but in the Summers
he was a wahoo and he did all this [__]
and you know me and him never really
[__] hit it all right you didn't like
a wahoo I didn't like him I never liked
him and I don't think he liked me so it
made it and we knew this in freshman
year I got along with all the drug
teachers but I didn't get along with him
but to make my story short in those days
in 78 79 and 80. Pullman would charge
you 35 bucks for a stick with the weed
had grown around it and it had come
right it would come right to the school
in those days in the Box
he'd show you the [__] box right from
Hawaii
and he would sell you this is 82. I
don't know if you you remember you were
probably in your daddy's pants my nose
no no I'm born 73.
so
that was his [__] claim to fame you
know so
I don't know what he called it he didn't
call it Maui wow he called it something
different it even came in a cellophane
thing in those days it was 35 bucks and
you got barely three joints it was
sticky as [__] you had to let it dry by
the time it dried Lee it was two joints
okay so that was my experience with it
but there was a spot in Harlem and they
sold Hawaiian wheat
at that time by a by 80 81 82 I was
pretty comfortable in those days smoking
a half a joint
taking a ride going to get a milkshake
or a half a Cuban sandwich with a friend
and I go home smoke the other joint and
within 20 minutes it was lalaville
and that's how I used it I'm not gonna
lie to anybody for years I knew one
thing I knew two things about marijuana
by 1985 I knew two things about
marijuana at the age of 22. I knew that
it put me to [__] sleep and I also
knew that when I smoked it and I put my
Walkman on which is I I is an iPod today
used to be a [__] Walkman you have to
add 50 [__] cassettes in your pockets
and all that [__] and nothing was better
in life than doing that and just going
for a walk in New York City nothing was
better than that
and then I discovered what's that I did
not in those days I still listened to
heavy metal and then I realized later on
after I started coming let me tell you
something
you know and you guys look at it as a
crutch but it worked for me guys and
that's all that [__] matter but I'll
tell you Lee knows Lee's my witness Lee
how much did we laugh on the way to the
pipe store to the bong store we got a
bong out of respect for Chris he's
Hawaiian I didn't want to disrespect
them how many how much did we left the
entire way I was half high already you
know me always and I write a joke when I
look at that [__] joke it makes the
joke funnier if I giggle when I'm high
that's a good [__] joke if me and Lee
giggle will [__] it's a funny [__]
joke you know when I used to act all the
time I get a script I read it when I'm
sober I read it I read it I read it I
read it I read it I read it I read it
and then I color it
and then I smoke a joint
and I read it I read it I read it I read
it I read it I read and then guess what
I do I go for a walk and smoke a joint I
don't look at it in 15 minutes then I
come back and I [__] read it read it
read it now I Mark the actions down what
exactly I'm gonna do I do that on the
weed for years that's how I booked rolls
it was a one-hour process and after that
just how I saw it is how I [__]
rehearse the BAM and I would make a
scene
out of the audition I wouldn't just go
in there and read anymore
I learned how to sell it how to slow it
down and exactly what I would do if I
was walking in the room to kick the door
into Sealy or if I was walking in to
have a conversation with you what
exactly do I do I turned the light on I
close the door I'm not gonna just walk
and leave the [__] door open you
close the [__] door you pull the
chair aside you walk over to the middle
you look around you go nice [__] digs
that's not even in the [__] script
but that's what you see when you smoke
that [__] number you understand me
so I understand do you have you heard of
people going to audition Stone
or or I did it and you know it got me
[__] because you're adrenaline goes up
and you don't know what's at the other
side of that door if they say to you
you're gonna go see producers you don't
know if it's one chick with a [__]
assistant or you don't know if it's
eight [__] and one of the
actors
you know what do you do if you smoke a
joint you think your life is [__]
beautiful and you walk into a room
and it's travolt in there with the
[__] casting director and the
directors uh the little [__] [__]
what do you do if you're stoned your
adrenaline shoots up a thousand over one
you're gonna start stuttering your hands
gonna start shaking with the script on
it you don't know how bad life is to
your hand is shaking with a script and
you're trying to read and you're falling
apart at the seams you know you know
what audition that happened to me on
which one The Sopranos no way first time
I went in there the producers my hand
was shaking like I was getting [__] in
the ass you understand me I couldn't
stop that twist my little hand was on
fire and [__] I was just reaching out
for somebody to get me out to get that
[__] that's how bad my hand was shaking
and you could hear this sheet going
oh so that's what happens when you smoke
weed it's like when you smoke weed and
you go to Jujitsu the first couple times
it's great until three hundred pound fat
dude gets on top of you and that 300
pound feels like 9 000 and you're out of
air and even after he gets up you smell
salami and [__] cold cuts and [__]
marinada and whatever else you [__]
saw so Mommy
let me get some shout outs here
look at my man Chris you want another
star I wanna go order some food now oh
yeah I forget the lion stuff out oh
please you know I don't [__] around here
first off the big shout out is to my
boys in Philadelphia thank you ladies
for coming out all you guys the poor
girl I was gonna smoke in the alley with
but it was a [__] nightmare I love
you Philly [__] my man trade
the insurance guy is always babla Lingus
thank you for the [__] present my
daughter loved it the baseball's
tremendous Garrett Nick Richardson thank
you for the cards the card I gave Lee
and thank you for the one you gave me
thank you for coming for the show and
thank you for being a bad [__]
I'm sorry I didn't smoke some bonus or
life for you listen when I do those
helium shows guys there's 250 people on
the way out and it's 250 people on the
way in
and I spoke to the staff and they were
like it's a [__] [__]
you go outside the people next door
complain like they did last time so you
really can't go outside because in
Philly where the [__] you gonna smoke
you can't smoke on that [__] Street
there like animals the only gets pissed
off so forgive me if I didn't come out I
came out I took a few pictures with a
few people when I won the herd came down
you know I love you [__] with
all my heart so thank you very much for
coming out also my [__] main girl
over there Hillary
she don't she's like a [__] bad cold
she don't stop tormenting me but Dylan
happy birthday this Wednesday [__]
whoever the [__] your birthday is I'll
see you [__] in October
15th I know you got tickets you know I
love you [__] Freddie Chavez my
man down on the Frank Buck a tenth
planet down there
and Thomas [__] eboard whatever
your [__] name is also a shout out to
my man
Mickey what's his name uh anyway don't
[__] matter Nick Gregorius who
actually I met the dude who's on the
podcast last week I met him the other
night it was 102 [__] degrees at six
o'clock
he had his ghee on I had my Gian and he
made me close my eyes and just [__]
breathe and roll with him
was one of the most amazing things that
ever happened to me I never sweat so
much in all my [__] life I was
thirsty for two [__] days you
understand me I was I was having dreams
that I was [__] thirsty but I want to
give a shout out to him and support his
black black belt uh Brotherhood black
belt Brotherhood because I tell you what
guys he's the real deal he showed up he
didn't accept any [__] money he told
me to give it to some donation
Brotherhood the Jujitsu Brotherhood and
he just taught me two or three little
things and you know what this guy was
sweating like an animal and most people
charge you 400 a [__] hour to do
something like that he wouldn't even
take the small half year nothing nothing
so uh if you're a Jiu-Jitsu person
supporters videos all these guys that
come in here him and Matt Baker these
guys are solid [__] so what's
the direction that you want your company
to go into right now the CBD oil what
are the things that you're looking to do
what is the rules you're looking to
[__] change I mean right now you're
shipping it to 50 states right now I'm
in Pennsylvania I get flashbacks of
Vietnam I I want to I get her just to
play the drums and somebody wants to get
some of this stuff right
um well there's gonna be uh we have a
website and uh they can go to this
website get the information off the site
to go ahead and get this it's called a
globalcbd.org
and they can go there and they can go
ahead and get it from that site right
there and and just go and there's no law
limits the DEA is not going to knock on
the door like an episode of cops
hey it's dietary supplement
it's a dietary supplement
it's not a drug there's no you can't get
high here our THC level is so low it's
like granola we're Beyond legal it's
like maybe they make they make uh
shampoo like this with the stuff in it
they put that they sell that everywhere
they they have cereal you can get like
this you have hearts you can buy in the
health food stores I mean you can buy
this CBD oil stuff in health food stores
as it is as well you know I just I want
to make sure people get CBD oil and get
the highest quality that they can find
you know
um prefer to stay away from the sugar
and and stay away from alcohol based CBD
oils one of the diseases is that
you know touches everybody touches every
bit at some point in your life
you wake up every morning every time
after a certain age you wake up every
morning you get a certain pain
and and the first thing that comes to
you mind is cancer you really can't be
an American if
a certain age you get a certain thing
you find the lump you you know something
and that's the first thing that comes to
your [__] mind
truth is like your number two fear you
know I hear you are sleeping you don't
drink you don't smoke you eat healthy
and all of a sudden you get this this
urge or you your stomach or
you know blood whatever whatever it is
and you go to a doctor and get it
checked out you know
before I start chemo
do I go see a holistic doctor to put me
on a certain balance of this you see I
could attack it for six weeks maybe are
people doing that have you heard of that
that's the [__] that has to get the [__]
out there that's what some guy has to go
on 16 minutes and go listen
[__] let me tell you something
this guy came in here with a lump under
his [__] shoulder he couldn't even
move it nobody know what the [__] it was
it was a form of cancer what we did
before radiation
is we took certain CBDs we rubbed it
topically and we also gave them certain
Doses and they gave him a certain type
of treatment
and within eight weeks it went away they
did another test 16 weeks later it was
not back they did another test 16 weeks
more late it's not back and now the
guy's living a healthy life that's what
we need to see on 60 Minutes to get
people on this [__] boat and even
then
don't be skeptical because see people
are looking for a get well that's the
problem with CBD people they think it's
like seeing Bigfoot right everything in
life with America right now nobody wants
to take the long road they want to take
the shortcut so even people that weigh
400 pounds or go wait a second maybe if
I take a CBD oil this will melt the fat
you know there's so many [__] people
that have bad intentions with this type
of stuff then they end up [__]
bad-mouthing it because they took it for
all the [__] wrong reasons not to
mention you have to be realistic with
yourself for example
immediately we're just sitting here as
decent Americans
but right now let me tell you something
okay so
Paul is going to move in with Lee
after six months every time Lee wakes up
Paul is not in bed with him no more
Lee puts on eight pounds even though
he's going to kettlebell class
and uh he's eating he can't figure it
out he's not he has no ice cream at the
house he doesn't go to eat with Joe Diaz
No tacos he's been eating fish chicken
breasts hummus bowls he hasn't missed
kettlebells he has not done all this
[__]
where the [__] am I going with this
story anyway
what's gonna happen when I gain weight
after Paul movies no no no no no no no
that's why you can't do this
smoke reefer because they both mix and
that's the end of that thing no no where
were we talking about here I don't even
[__] know where I was going with this
just about how some people have bad
intentions okay okay I'm sorry he wakes
up one morning and he goes Paula why do
you keep [__] sleeping on her hand
she goes listen you're snoring man
you know you're [__] snoring when I
first met you you didn't [__] snore
what are you doing that you're snoring
you got to start smoking pot with Joey
Diaz so all of a sudden he goes home and
tells [__] Paul he don't smoke pot
with Joey Diaz but guess what he's doing
his snoring is getting worse and worse
one night Paula says You know what last
night you were choking this is basic
America because this is what I did guys
so there you are you're starting to
choke you want to prove her wrong the
first thing you buy is the nose strip
okay
you buy that [__] stupid nose strip
and you know how much that works zero
zero okay then the second thing you do
is I was expecting something to happen
with those right nothing happens let's
be honest and then the second so it's
like losing the 699 but we complain's
about 6.99 nobody but they make [__]
four dollars times 10 million [__]
times and we become [__] idiots
because that [__] will never work for
you then you buy the syrup or something
they tell you smoking dope cures it and
you buy that [__] and that don't work
then they tell you to buy some syrup you
put on your [__] nose and that don't
work a mouth guard then you're up one
night and I just saw that now they're
really pushing that [__] mouth guard
I don't know what they want for it guys
if you're choking in your sleep and
you're snoring okay do me a favor don't
buy that [__] mouth guard
don't buy that mouth guard you might as
well take the forty dollars do Coke one
last time and go see the doctor and tell
them to request that you need a sleep
study [__] day and that's it there's
no liquid that works that Band-Aid don't
work the [__] invention on TBS don't
work the [__] machine that they sell
on stupid [__] uh my friend I got an
email he bought a hundred and something
dollar machine at that place on what my
point is is so many [__] people take
all these shortcuts before really
securing their remedy
you know what I'm saying like there was
a remedy you knew that you needed to go
take a sleep after your study but the
whole time you've been taking shortcuts
with no strips and [__] she
would do for your mouth yeah because you
actually believe that guy on TV that you
ain't gonna [__] snore no more you
know what why don't you just go to
[__] uh uh what's the store where
they sell [__] rash guards and knee
pads right there on Burbank Boulevard
which is a boxing store no not the
boxing store the other one with the go
in there and my [__] mouthpiece
what's the difference
for 3.99 buy a [__] mouthpiece what's
the one they sell you Authority yeah go
to Sports Authority and buy a [__] 10
mouthpiece and give it a shot if that
don't work for you need to go see a
[__] doctor it's the same difference
don't tell me it has a spoon yeah it's
choking me that that's a that's just
[__] what sleep happen is well that's
what I don't want people to do with CBD
oils
that's we're lazy as Americans we're
looking to push effects oh I tried that
it didn't [__] them well you stupid
[__] you tore that [__]
playing football they had your leg
hanging yeah there's actually people in
America that will resist taking care of
that thing
because they know what they did and they
know what the result is something isn't
right I know my knee is not right I'm
telling you that but you want me to tell
you something my wrist wasn't right when
I started going to Jujitsu and yeah I do
the mobility exercises and everything
but I don't have that constant little
pain anymore
yeah if you throw me on my back and I go
to [__] kimori and I land and I go to
pop-up I'm gonna get a little sharp in
action that's 300 [__] pounds on my
wrist right right but it's not that
constant pain like I said that's what
I've noticed yeah yeah so all those
little things is what people have to be
honest with themselves whenever they go
for a CBD I don't want them to think
this is the end-all bill I want you to
look at this objectively with an open
mind you're hearing the reports you know
what Google it I Googled it up your dose
up your dose I Googled it Google it
[__] tonight when you're there
by yourself in the office tomorrow
Google [__] CBD oil and the benefits
and then Google what's the what's the
what's the opposite of benefits
um
cons the pros and the cons benefits and
you're going to be [__] pretty
impressed with what you're reading yeah
there's newspaper articles in This Time
magazine articles and you know what Lee
what'd you say you watch book the other
day whatever his name was and he went
and bunch of different kids what's his
name oh um
Sanjay Gupta yeah whatever this [__]
name is
whatever his name is you know what I
mean I'm bad with names
it was pretty interesting I've seen it a
lot what was he talking about he
he said a lot of theories about it but
this specific episode that I watched I
was a five-year-old girl from I believe
in New Jersey he moved to uh Colorado
because she was having two seizures
every hour
and like the app like it was it wasn't
it wasn't uh Parkinson's or whatever it
was it was a different disease
but like the kids often die pretty young
and like the dad was like a a marine so
he didn't want to do weed and the mom
was like the
the the perfect soccer mom like image
and she didn't want weed but they saw
that it had worked and how are they
giving a weed at first in an oil and the
doctor didn't want to give it to her
because it was she was too so young and
and uh at the end she just totally
totally transformed her did they take
the hallucinogenic qualities out of it
or it was CBD oil CBD oil if I
understand correctly from what I've seen
is it just doesn't have it it it's a CBD
has a very low THC percentage and THC is
the hallucinogenic
so it's not that they take it out it's
just that it has low THC and they talk
to um they talk to some growers in
Colorado and they said it's just a
process of cloning and like mating
plants
in a certain way and I'm about this is
the worst explanation of it I understand
but they breed them in a certain way to
get the THC as low as possible in the
CBD as high as possible
and then that's
and then yeah and then they talk to this
one dude who had a disease where his
like abdomen wouldn't stop tensing like
he couldn't he could never catch his
breath which sounds horrible oh my gosh
and he he's oh my God it's like me oh I
know exactly that's what I was thinking
but he like he looked he's skinny
and he like it was right like you could
see and on the stomach the muscle's just
going and he had all these pills that he
was on and then he gave it to him he
took on the show it was pretty funny he
couldn't really talk and then he took
one puff off of like a up a bull and
then within like two words of the
sentence he was like a valedictorian
again it was pretty crazy
it's a
I had a friend who was stubborn whenever
he did a line of coke he would stop
stuttering I saw that for years I saw
that I saw over my own eyes he would be
like an opera singer when he'd be the
two plastic coke before that he'd be
stuttering spitting
it's a [__] nightmare now listen
people uh
I've always told you how I feel I've
never [__] come on to you with
nothing [__] creepy or nothing like
this this is something I believe in I've
read enough about it I I know what I've
been feeling lately I know what my body
felt like I mean I got thrown you know
dog 300 [__] pounds does damage to
your body yeah I'm trying to get healthy
and the calisthenics and the [__]
whatever
but I felt a different transformation
and all those little nooks and crannies
that you get you know I sleep on my side
what do you think my shoulders are like
every morning I wake up my little
shoulder pain I gotta twitch it a little
bit and maybe move that do with that
Mobility [__] on my shoulder and get the
[__] rubber red thing on my [__]
thing and do twists and pull it I don't
have that the last [__] three weeks
so thank you for turning me on that's
why I just want to let the world know
that this is available to them when I
got this from you I did not know that
this was legal in all 50 states so if
there's people listening to this
and you know somebody or uh
you know maybe you just want to help
yourself
go to what webpage
or that paycheck just a second
it is the globalcbd.org
and what uh do you know any
experience that it has with like
Alzheimer's and Dementia and stuff like
that I haven't I haven't uh
had the opportunity to work with anybody
with like Alzheimer's yet
um I have worked with autistic kids
um cancer patients uh PTSD doesn't have
uh does it help with with Alzheimer's is
that is that one of the things that it
works with I can't really say it because
I haven't seen it but
um my Bogey's seen a lot of things and
we have a lot of testimonies on our site
you can see it last week something came
out
about this and dementia I know it works
really good with opening up other areas
of your brain which is to me that's
something I want I read something can I
quote it no I can't quote it I didn't
write it down I didn't know the
scheduling I didn't know what his
schedule was going to be I should have
paid more attention but I did read
something about the prevention I didn't
read deeper into if it was smoking it or
eating it or just a CBD oil but I did
read a positive article about it and
like I said guys you know I've been
doing this show with you guys for five
[__] years
I've never sat here you know telling you
I'm Betsy Ross's nephew but a thousand
people can't be [__] lying no this
this [__] this uh what do you call
that this Gold Rush
to Colorado for people's children and
people's parents and and all these
different treatments for veterans is not
[__] people wouldn't just pick up and
run people just wouldn't uproot
themselves you know but they want their
children to to live and be legal and be
able to go to school and for people to
understand that's why my question really
was if they get it will they test
positive that's there's yeah there's
nothing in here man I mean I I uh I have
people that that have jobs where they
get tested all the time and there's no
high in this there's no high for them
now when they do the piss test they've
never or in over a year we've never had
anybody come dirty and a piss test it's
clean it's healthy it's just a dietary
supplement it's legal it's like it's
like going to the store and eating like
uh condensed pear juice or something
like that you know what I mean
is that's all it is like I said man
thank you for opening up my eyes to this
because I have been thinking a lot about
this I've been reading a lot about this
I have a child
if I got put into a position
would I do it
have you ever seen a child suffer I'd
have to give it a chance
so but that's me I'm a little
open-minded I understand I I get it that
I understand the pharmaceutical business
and how it works so
this is why I wanted to bring this to
you to your attention if you know
somebody go on the webpage one more time
Global CBD
.net nope no Global
globalcbd.org you see what I'm dealing
with I got Lee's [__] Cousins in here
now and don't forget I'm taking salami
and stuff man I'm doing the whole uh no
expectations tour
starting July 21st at Flappers in the
[__] Yahoo room and August 4th the
Flappers in the Yoo-hoo room then August
31st I'm at the ice house then September
8 I'm Flappers in the Yoo-hoo room then
September 28th I'm back at the ice house
then October 4th I'm at the comedy store
then October 11th I'm at the comedy
store again you know cheap tickets me
working on my material for the [__]
special you'd be helping me out you know
I love you [__] all right listen
number one you know I love these people
on it.com they got some [__] gut
health you got to take a look at they
got some emulsified MCT oil you gotta
take a look at they got some vitamin D3
MCT spray they got the krill oil listen
you know me baby that hemp Force protein
is how I work it out every morning it's
like a banana some ice cubes you know
nice nice it fills you up now I like it
it works for me gives me some [__]
energy you know I've always been a uh
shrimp type of guy I just a little
scared lately with their nose operation
I don't want to be able to breathe too
much and I got a heart attack from too
much [__] oxygen and uh you know me
with the [__] Alpha Brain 100 money
back guarantee no [__] questions
asked as usual I'm not a scientist go to
audit.com right now and they'll tell you
whatever the [__] you need to do and
after that you make your decisions I
can't help you with the weights but
supplements I'm your [__] Uncle Joey
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you
10 points off your first order go to
honda.com go to the box and tell them
Church
c-h-u-r-c-h slinging dick and giving out
bubble gum over that on it you'll feel
better you'll look better and you'll be
motivated get out there [__] it's
summertime nobody wants to stay in
playing checkers everybody wants to be
out [__] with binoculars getting
their dick sucked at the beach go to
honors.com right now number two
what's the name of it again Global what
is it the Globus CD cbd.org damn give it
a shot Columbus did give it a shot
Columbus did free shipping nothing what
do they get shipping all right go right
there right now your grandmother she's
acting funny she's talking about [__]
blowing Sinatra get some CBD oil Take It
To The Hoop Lisa yet Lisa yeah you ready
for another store
you know what I think I'm okay all right
just checking I know you're over there
[__] lonely of it and as usual my
bank my main [__] listen Dot susara
that [__] uh the the pouchy little
bag there again I wonder what's it
called Fanny Patrick I'm sorry you know
me I smoked a couple [__] stars today
the fanny pack I took it to [__]
Philly and back again the wallet the
cell phone
the [__] Q-tips in case my [__]
heads [__] up on the plane I Spit on
them and I put them in my mind here
or I dip them in the water I don't give
a [__] same difference
all right and then what else did I have
in there I had my vapor pen in there I
had my [__] chewing gum in there you
know that's the way it is and it's right
in front of you don't lose it even when
you put the seat belt on Boom it fit
over it like a doctor nobody touches you
there you got your [__] secure not only
that I love the gym bag they gave me one
of the best gym bags I've ever had you
know why because I'm like a [__]
secret agent I got more sippers and more
hidden compartments I got two on this
side one for water one for another water
and one for a [__] package of uh
protein powder for after your workout on
the other one I got my nose spray on the
other one I got my cell phone inside I
got backup knee pads I got a [__]
gift certificate I got a resume you know
me Uncle Joey I got a [__] BB gun I
got a blow dot my point is it's a
durable bag it's like it's a nice
shoulder strap you can carry it the
[__] thing opens up or close it the
zipper they come with an extra bag to
put your dirty rash guard and listen
this is the [__] bag you've been
looking for go to dsgear.com right now
I'm gonna give you five percent on they
also have a 15 rash guard an Eco rash
guard they work with hemp [__]
not only that they support the ebi
they're they're part of the [__] game
do me a favor go to DS gear right
now.com and take a look at even if you
just take the rash guard in the fanny
pack listen you know me I'm gonna love
you no matter what if you like [__]
uh bouncing on dicks I don't like I love
everybody I'm here to love everybody all
right I want to thank Allen I want to
thank you Joey Joey for dsgear.com I'm
gonna give you five percent off
you really are underway too oh what I'm
worried you packing Q-tips in the fanny
pack you know what I mean oh Jesus I can
take care of myself don't you get my
vitamins in there oh of course vitamins
I got my vitamins in there my blood
pressure medication I guess I get
delayed at the airport I got a [__]
uh I got a phone charger in there in
case I get delayed an airport I got a
vapor pen I might have a few Edibles
hidden disguised and something else not
even Pablo Francisco's dogs could sniff
them out you understand me I got you
know when I travel you got to look good
you got a toothbrush in there kiss they
give you peanuts on the plane you don't
want to come out in chunks on your
[__] date you know a little tuba
[__] thing
Visine yeah you gotta take care of
yourself Lee
gotta take care of yourself you come
prepared that's why I like that little
[__] fanny pack people think the
fanny pack is dead the fanny pack is
dead if you're a stylist [__] Momo
but if you're a businessman you got your
cash in that all [__] yeah the only
fanny pack I can see you wearing is the
one from Uncle Grandpa now the other I
hate what you do here's what you really
do because you know me I'm a Jew I can't
tell you I put the wallet in there just
case I gotta get into a duel with a
[__] he rips the thing off the
wallet's always in the front pocket and
the [__] cell phone's always in the
left okay you follow what I'm saying to
you but you know what I'm saying making
people Maps you got back up whatever the
[__] you want to do anyway I love you
[__] like I said the no
expectations tour anywhere from Flappers
you who room Tuesday nights Thursday
nights early I get you out early no
[__] drama and come down and we'll
[__] Chit Chat Leo tape and Leo be
there with us taping taking [__]
notes like my producer and that's it
that's how it works out I want to thank
Chris ta Loa for [__] being on the
show and breaking down CBDs for your
[__] I hope you guys enjoyed it
and I'll see you guys on Wednesday have
a good night stay black
oh
all right
foreign